hello everyone Karen warden with film
courage the radio show we're here
outside the studio after our interview
with Claire wassman and Fernando nor the
teeth the team behind the comedy the
Grover complex and also partners and
pretension and one of the questions that
we wanted to get to was what are you
doing differently with partners and
pretension the web series that you
didn't do with the Grover complex you
had the indie film feature and now
you've taken on the series of web you
know shows what what kind of lessons
have you learned um definitely learned
if it's a for Grover it's you know not a
subject a lot of people are comfortable
with and we didn't do much social media
before we actually finish the film or
four got a trailer and so then it was
like got the film done got trailer and
bam please everyone pay attention to us
um and that's not really how it works I
mean it especially with the the context
of the film I think if we had started
before with more of like flawless
through production a follow us through
our ideas I think it would have been a
better way to kind of ease people in so
definitely for partnership retention
we're trying to get people involved
while before we have everything finished
we're doing like a character blog trying
to get a twitter going just so we have
some sort of connection with people
before we actually have footage and we
just expect people to to take notice we
just have to like you know get some sort
of like i would say audience that you
know that are interested in it like
before it's finished because with Grover
was just like we finished
and then we had no why did I even have a
facebook pic did i do man Twitter good
sigh do you have any of that stuff but
uh you know I'm now with partners like
we have we have all those accounts where
people can like follow us and see the
progress we're making with Grover with
made everything until I'm only with them
oh yeah so was just let me do slide on
ya doing we have a marketing budget we
do plan on getting some people people
involved for the marketing because the
web is so full of so much content and
even if you do get social media going I
mean what is to make people pay
attention to yours over over other ones
so well we are going to be having people
do a media strategy for us otherwise you
know if it's just supposed to show on
the web and you can't get the ball on
the web to watch then you've kind of
wasted your time sighs the experience
the great experience so what's the
reason that you're doing a web series
now when you've already done a
successful film what's worse this shift
come into play um like we have some
feature scripts would like to do later I
wanted to get into directing and we knew
that if I just had a feature-length film
when I was like I've never directed
before give me a directing job then I
think people would look at us like we
were nuts and also it was something that
felt like a more manageable size after
we finished the feature um you know
there's that for some people it's you
finish the film you think everything's
gonna be magic and then it's not
immediately magic and you for the mood
goes down so it's like instead of
throwing ourselves into another feature
film let's do a web series which is more
manageable bites well kind of flex
different muscles and keeping things
concise and keep us busy I think it's
important to keep yourself busy and then
also as I mentioned there's hopefully
kind of a tie-in between the two
projects if you like Grover hopefully
you should like aspects of partnership
retention if you like partnership
retention there should be things in the
garba complex that you enjoy yeah I know
definitely just getting out of that
depression from the feature you know so
just to keep doing projects and just get
more experience you know just just keep
adding to our best to our experience
basically and you know a feature is just
so much mark so painful to make because
like like you said although the market
and getting like crew together for so
many days as where the web series we can
shoot like a smaller episodes you know
10 and 12 and it once and you know it's
just more experience adding more you
know experience as a good at that so
where does that rebirth come from when
you're in that depression and you're
eating junk food you're watching access
hollywood days where where where do you
say you know what I'm gonna do this
again okay and it didn't happen the way
I wanted it to turn out but where does
that rebirth occur whoa okay well for me
it's just listening to certain songs or
something or just watching boxing or or
any kind of things thing with sports for
me because it's just desperation you
know it's like you can do it you know so
anything that can come from music movies
sports uh you know just that drive you
know I don't know it's just to keep
going um just can come from anywhere a
speaker yeah fired by Speaker I think
everyone should have a couple books or
something that they like each other they
can always go to with certain lessons or
biographies people they like just
something they can draw on and then I
think we just stopped back to how much
energy we had during the feature like I
just like working a nine-to-five then
after that we'd go to
our souls that we go to pre production
planning but we just had like endless
energy and it's like we want to get back
to that how do we get back to that and
see excitement so it's like even though
you were down it's like if you can think
back to things that made you happy even
though I mean always yeah you're
intentionally going to head back to
drilling down again um but I think
that's a mistake a lot of people make
and we had teachers tell us after you
make something have something else ready
to go and we had more big projects ready
to go um that we just weren't ready to
stomach yet so I think even if when you
get done with a feature if you have a
few scenes to shoot or you have
something else you're working on that
feels manageable after you know putting
so much energy into a feature that's
better than just waiting for something
to happen and just have little
activities well I mean for me after just
finishing the feature and having
projects going simultaneously I think
for a first feature and that is so easy
to say but so hard to do because I mean
like you can have I mean it's everything
will be amazing to have projects going
simultaneously but you need to focus if
it's your first feature or is your first
project you've gotta have that first
project be done right you know instead
of like focusing on on another project
that you might be directing or anything
I mean if it's your first project you
need to make sure it's ya mean it's good
to make sure that you do the door right
do deliver do a good job on it you know
so I I mean it just I mean yeah like
teachers did say like to have other
projects going but I mean it's so easy
to say but it's so hard to do especially
when you're like well you have two
producers on on the project and you have
no marketing strategy or no assistance
or none of that stuff how are you gonna
have another project going when you
don't even have like any marketing for
this other one or any post production
experience you're like basically
learning
of you know so hey if it is for other
people could do it that's cool but for
our first feature i just went soul it's
so hard you know and lastly how do you
plan on releasing the webseries partners
and pretension oh we plan on trying to
go through like a four um we think we
want to do weekly every it deals with um
the story episode and then there's like
a fun more interactive how to episode
and so at least for the first one you're
going to release those together but
basically we have episodes and then we
have additional bonus content that are
almost as long as some other web series
like sometimes you know webseries it
like two to three minutes long and
that's about the length of our how to's
whereas our story episodes are like over
10 minutes long so um we found releasing
those together probably weekly and we'd
like to tie in somehow to our audience
or which we think that you know a lot of
college kids will like the program and
better like but uh but ya know when we
hopefully getting some sponsorship we're
talking you with that stuff too so it's
having a play I just going into it like
uh how miracles gonna happen for just a
big of lad so important don't give up
but don't think that there's gonna be
some divine intervention you still have
to push through it yes push I mean it's
great to have like that quality and
everything to do a fantastic job when
you're moving everything but you also
gotta have that audience and just people
wanting to see it because I mean there's
so much stuff you do see just out of
because of marketing you know so uh Dan
marketing is hard yeah uh clearly talk
about marketing I mean if you don't know
I mean I think it's a learning process
if you don't know something if you don't
think you have a handle on it then
that's when I think you do get somebody
else involved like we've done
most things ourselves but then we try to
admit or at least be conscious of when
yes it was not our best area so then we
sy for the feature we've given it off to
you know a sales rep because in terms of
us handling it ourselves I think it
would take longer I like it severely
taken advantage we sent to many DVDs out
with no response that we do like you
know what like this is an aspect that we
don't really know much about that we
need somebody to help us out with yeah
so yeah so we will be having someone man
except for us for the web series